I'm sweating and it's not even that hot
in here I just think I'm so nervous
hi I'm Paris Kennedy I'm Danny Wilde and
I am a porn star my name is Zach and I'm
definitely not a porn star I'm about to
watch some porn with Ali Hayes that she
stars in I'm a straight guy and I'm
about to watch some gay porn I don't
really watch straight porn that often I
don't know if this is the point where I
admit that like I feel like I've almost
definitely seen important with you in it
before my expectations are pretty high
this is a really old scene I do act
quite a bit in this it's broken down as
intro [ __ ] sex 1 6 2 I also just
notice this is one take that's insane
that's like Birdman no kissy you just
gone for it girl I'm sorry I just keep
getting distracted by this frame it's
kind of like flesh just nice kissing -
there's the peepee I think it's awesome
that porn stars say peepee well spank
it's getting good
do they direct you to do the spank or is
that just like now I'm in it I'm feeling
it it was in the script wieners out you
guys do you like it when they talk to
you yeah you're like really good at
sucking dick thank you oh my god that
means yes oh there's three guys here yes
so many just like appendages that's a
really big penis this is amazing Oh
beautiful heinous thank you how much
time you guys sit before like draw this
out like a football players up to the
camera guy really your abs must be
killer like your core strength holy [ __ ]
you're like in the gym just like yeah
that's a typical on you look at how much
you're sweating holy crap the roller
skates are making me taller so yes if
its own are you being spit-roasted well
I don't have a dick in my butt our most
porn stars like like circumcised worse
now circumcised is that a I'm actually
not circumcised I could tell me I did I
did that is something I was able to tell
very quickly oh wow oh my god we are
really going for it right now
how well do you know these these guys
Madame it seems very professional
oh that I just met them and I can you
just like dive right in yeah totally I
would be nervous if I had to do like a
kissing scene it doesn't take a toll on
you physically I mean I know my body
well enough that
I'm ready to be done I'm like time you
do this especially what's happening in
our ear right now and then like some
moans do you have to like do that to
your coochie cat no it's kind of just
for the visual for the viewer like are
you enjoying this let's freeze on this
close-up of your testicles this is
almost like abstract art I could see
that it like hung up and like some old
person's apartment they don't even know
what it is it's not my my style but I
appreciate it I get it I'm pretty
familiar with all the equipment you guys
are working with you know he's about to
come they do a little fade solely to
it'll show it like five times like in
slow motion he's gonna come on the
roller skate oh alright well that was
the thing we did I think it's really
interesting like to hear like how these
actually get put together yeah it's not
as awkward as I thought it would be
there's a normal guy dude I'm commend
you for actually sitting here and doing
that because I couldn't finish somebody
like watch me ask that I would be
worried that they'd be like you like it
like that that's what you do I'm not
gonna lie I have a little like softy oh
wow it's like such a big compliment from
a gay guy like I want to cry I'm glad my
first time watching was well thank you
is special for me too I just show you
some of my videos but I think they're
not as exciting I think that's only fair
right but I do get naked anybody you got
a nice little bulge in there yeah points
are respecting the bowls I'm into that